[Music]
all right H you're tired you're hot it's
been a long day shake shake it out a
little bit shake it out alright yeah
here we are so I'm gonna talk about
economics the package management more
specifically at open source it's I'm
gonna tell you a story I'm gonna tell
you a story about who owns the
JavaScript language Commons how we got
into this situation where the JavaScript
language Commons is by someone and why
we need to change it this is a story
about money and ownership and control as
much as it is about JavaScript I am
going to tell you this story
and I'm gonna tell you the version of
the story I know how to tell I am one
human being with imperfect knowledge and
a point of view so this story is not the
only story anyone could tell about it
not by a long way
but I can tell you a good version of one
slice of this story because I was part
of it
I was at its heart because until last
year I was CTO of NPM Inc the company
that runs the JavaScript package
registry this gives me an expertise on
the topic few people in the world have
it also comes with a point of view that
I'm going to invite you to keep my point
of view in mind as you hear this story
you are in this story yes you I bet you
didn't know that you're part of this
story by the time I'm done you'll know
why you're part of it and why your
participation matters it's a story about
money people who have money and how the
people who make from open-source
software
I'm not the people who it's a story of
an accidental decision that you made
without knowing about it
one that I made consciously and how that
decision worked out today so story about
ownership control
and their consequences it's also a story
about power who has it how much of it
you have and what you can do with it are
you ready all right here we go
do you remember Yahoo our stories kind
of starts with Yahoo back in its glory
days in the mid-2000s JavaScript was the
heart of a lot of JavaScript activity
back then it employed a lot of thought
leaders like Douglas Crockford and it
was pushing the state of the art forward
might not have had a good business plan
but it had a good tech stack and one
thing that yahoo had in its tech stack
was a package manager it was called ypm
and it apparently did some pretty neat
things people who used it liked it but
at the same time that all this was
happening and you know action in Yahoo
JavaScript was itself kind of taking off
in an interesting way thanks to things
like jQuery and browser makers deciding
to actually adhere to a common spec for
once this was pretty great
javascript exploded server-side
JavaScript was just starting to be a big
Opik and it was here in 2009 10 years
ago where Ryan Dahle announced nodejs
and that turned out to be the JavaScript
platform we wanted on the server now the
early note community was pretty it was a
happen in place it was a scene it's it
swept up a whole bunch of interesting
people from systems programming and web
programming and people who really
enjoyed being at a bleeding edge
ecosystem where a whole lot of stuff
hadn't been invented yet
and several of the people involved in
early on figured out earlier on but you
know package management would be a
pretty great thing and there was a bunch
of package managers plural being written
yeah more than one one of these people
was a yahoo employee he was a super into
node he quit his jobs that he can write
something inspired by the Yahoo package
manager
but for nodejs and
this particular programmer was clever
and it supple a couple of really useful
ways for one thing he got really super
involved with node and this let him work
on both the outside implementation and
his package manager at the same time he
could make an installer work right and
he really championed the commonjs
implementation that node has and he did
you know some other stuff to beat other
package managers like going around to
all the packages and giving them pull
requests to support his instead of the
other one pretty smart
this was his was good enough and useful
enough was the right solution who's
supported well enough that it one so the
node package manager or NPM started
being put quite along with node instead
of living as a separate third-party
thing that you downloaded right after
your downloaded node the official status
granted by the node project continues to
today and right about this time joint
bot node from Ryan to offer a pretty
paltry amount of money really you'll
notice that we're already in interesting
economic territory the man who invented
nodejs
the tool used by everyone in this room
and millions of people daily to develop
javascript made a few tens of thousands
of dollars from it whoever's making
money from node today it's not his it's
inventor he did at least make a living
after selling it because giant hired him
that was pretty good and the giant also
hired the programmer who made nodes
package manager but important plot point
he retained ownership of it he retained
ownership of the NPM jeaious org domain
name the NPM source code and any
inventions in it as a known intellectual
property he didn't turn it all over to
join it the way the nodes source had
been turned over to giant
this decision matters later so notice it
the open source doesn't mean open
ownership or control it means you get to
read the source for something and the
ability to read part of the source from
them something doesn't mean you could
change that source it doesn't get you
any control over it what it does or what
it manages so our story moves forward
kind of a predictable way you've
probably heard this part before 2012
Dahle leaves the node project an NPM
owner steps up to lead it and instead
and right about here is where all of you
start appearing on the scene or some of
you anyway your JavaScript programmers
you like writing JavaScript if you can
write a tool in JavaScript you will so
you started writing JavaScript with node
and you liked it I mean while people
like me who are kind of mixed about
JavaScript don't tell anyone
I figured out that node it was pretty
handy for writing i/o multiplexing
services and I was like this is fun it's
2013 went on more and more people got on
the node train and node got pretty
popular
this meant NPM got pretty popular and
that's great right
well no success is a catastrophe for a
lot of projects it's a catastrophe you
need to survive and success for NPM was
a catastrophe here's why and PM's
packaged registry is centralized it's
not just a CLI tool that grabs the code
and puts it onto your hard drive into
node modules in fact the UI is probably
the least important part of the NPM
machinery despite how frequently you
interact with it NPM is most importantly
to all of you a centralized package
registry and repository and right from
the beginning the registry was there
running inside a couch DB database on
the same domain it's on today yeah a
couch TB and registry is just a list of
all the packages you can install their
authors their names
versions the repository part is the part
that stores all those packages and
centralized spot and this is pretty
great because it makes installing them
fast and reliable someone can work on
making that central repository zippy as
a lot to unpack there I think it's worth
a Mon of our time so let's do it
centralization is what we're talking
about here and centralization has some
advantages am/pm registry is centralized
it comes with usability wins you only
need to go to one place to look for
something that one place can enforce
some rules about the thing you're
looking for that they all look the same
that they provide the same kinds of
information maybe they don't even vanish
on a whim when their owner gets bored
and centralization is it has advantages
matter to you I've been doing a go-go
programming lately and man that's weird
it's it's very strange to try to find
code packages because they're everywhere
and the only way to find them is to
google for them and you look at these
old-fashioned lists of really exciting
go packages you know the thing that
yahoo has to do this like handmade lists
of things and when I install these
packages I start from github repos that
can just vanish so I have expectations
that come from having used NPM for eight
years and go doesn't it mean any of
those expectations the absence of a
central registry forgoes helped me
really understand what NPM provides
every JavaScript programmer and in fact
centralization has been such an
advantage that it's a trend blogs blogs
where something used to host on your own
used to buy your own domain name and
spin up a server and host a blog it that
through the last ten years there's been
this big trend toward centralized
hosting platforms you know things that
can provide a reliable place for you to
put your blog like MySpace or poster
Asst Journal
okay tumblr and medium super social
media centralized Twitter and Facebook
and open sources even centralized not so
okay NPM is a centralized registry for
all the node packages there are and this
is great except in 2013 it wasn't great
why downside of centralization is that
costs are centralized downside of NPM
registry is that all that use centered
on a single database with an a prevent
inside it here's a fact of the world
servers cost money who pays for them for
years
no manager ran on donated hosting who's
written with help from some of the
people involved in implementing couchdb
so CouchDB was its database and it free
loaded on a bunch of coasts she be
hosting services it was for a long time
treated as an ad for CouchDB hosting for
by this company called iris couch you've
never heard from heard of iris couch was
bought by no jitsu they continued to
host nodes package manager until it was
a cheap bad right and then it wasn't so
cheap success the catastrophe is
expensive you all started using node and
that ad stopped being cheap and the
other various lazy shortcuts taken in
implementing the registry started having
an effect once the registry saw some
real use so the registry was down more
than it was up in October 2013
NPM needed money it needed a maintainer
didn't ignore it for his day job this is
not a particularly new problem every
language ecosystem at some point if they
have a centralized package registry also
has this problem
rubygems cost money to run to they run
on donations see Penn pearls package
network they solved their problem 20
years ago with a network of mirrors a
lot of smaller language ecosystems some
along by
freeloading on github public repos like
cocoapods and some others what M PM's
owner decided to is pretty novel he
decided to found a company this is
possible because he'd retained ownership
of it even while he was running the node
project he still owned NPM he quits
joyeux he founds company npm inc and he
takes seed funding for River VC firm
here's our decision white node project
decided this was fine they continue to
give NPM special privileges something
they bundle along I don't know if there
was internal controversy about this
because I wasn't part of part of it and
that project was entering kind of its
moribund to period around this time so
maybe the decision was made through
inaction I don't know but they continued
to affirmative lis decide that that's
what they want to do every year since
then you decided this was fine you voted
with your feet and kept using the NPM
registry but siege I hear you say I
wasn't around then
well you most of you probably weren't
around then you've inherited this
decision and you probably didn't know it
was a decision NPM is just out there as
a fun question fact of JavaScript life
you might not have even known it was a
company at all right the time it was
pretty controversial the company that
had been hosting NPM was really kind of
pissed off about it they had there been
up to their own fix with a scale NPM
funding campaign which ended up raising
a bunch of money for it at the same time
the VC money came in and there was there
was there were lawyers involved I don't
know much about this I just know that
MPM exited no jitsu hosting very quickly
and messily because the two companies
were fighting later on NPM exited Giants
hosting very quickly and messily because
they were also fighting I don't know
money
it changes everything and chips made but
it's all just open-source fun and under
the strain of competing for dollars is
another thing I decided this was fine I
decided to let Java scripts language
Commons be owned by venture capitalists
I didn't frame it that way to myself
though the decision I told myself I was
making was the district the decision to
contribute what I could to making nodes
successful it's a huge node fan really
liked programming a node I still do
and then pima's the first place that
ever participated in open source so MPM
inc in 2014 as a company it has VC money
it starts hiring people the first person
they hired was raquel villas who you've
heard speak at this very conference
second hire was me i was thrilled to
tell you the truth i wanted to make it
go better and i believe that the story
told by n PM's IP owner that we would
make NPM Inc self-sustaining and the
servers would hum along happily
dispensing packages for the masses
forever and ever so you know I ended up
leading an PM's engineering team you
know this part of the story large
numbers are very large you install lots
of packages MPM was successful it scaled
and node exploded as a result you
started using node to do everything an
NPM is now an unquestioned part of your
workflow you reinvented web development
in ways you couldn't do before NPM was
their reliable providing shared code
like it's some kind of utility it's a
highlight of an excellent career and I
still pretty proud of it let's pause
here we're at the absolute zenith of
nodes package manager let's talk about
money I love money
why isn't Ryan Dahle living on a
tropical island
why isn't James Halliday retired on a
tropical island the he lives on now why
isn't why isn't Dominick Tarr living in
a yacht instead of a sailboat did he
still live in a sailboat yeah
why does Doug Wilson have a day job do
you know those names they're the authors
of software you have on your laptop's
right now software that is the beating
heart of a thousand programs that
business runs every day every fortune
500 company there is runs the software
written by those people and dozens of
other people who I don't have time to
list who contributed packages to NPM in
the early days and do so even now those
people are not wealthy despite the
enormous value created by the software
they make capitalism it's unfortunately
as you probably already know capitalism
it's supposed to reward people like them
but in practice it doesn't here's the
thing most of us give away our source we
share it without expecting or ever
dreaming that we make money from it I
think most of the people I just named
contributed to JavaScript's Commons
without X without wanting their tropical
islets they might wish they had them but
they didn't expect them money was not on
their minds I was back in the early days
of node when they knew we all knows
contributors knew each other they were
just exchanging gifts with their peers
fellow node programmers all right now
here I want to talk about the difference
between the open source and free
software you're probably aware of this
difference it's the free software
Richard Stallman style and open source
eric raymond style the Stallman canoe
license like it's to make you have to
give away the things you make with the
source code you've shared and over here
in eric raymond land you know
it goes a little differently we can
argue about whether like Stallman's
canoe license achieves its goal or not
and I think people do argument links and
I'm not gonna join that argument right
now but I will point out that Eric
Raymond style free software or MIT
license and the BSD license and
permissive license is all certainly the
kind of open source you practice
particularly in the JavaScript and node
communities you treat the GPL like
poison you've chosen open source not
free software capitalism freaking loves
open source let me tell you companies
get a lot of good stuff for free and
they have no no requirements on them for
using it it's it takes it even further I
think by telling you that you have to do
this get hired github is your resume
they tell you and they stretch out their
hand to make the free software from you
to build things with Dominic gives
away pull stream and every fortune 500
company there is uses it and it doesn't
get compensated this is our reality I
don't think I can fix that you notice
that there was a person in this story I
didn't give his stuff away that's pretty
smart right he's the one who didn't give
away his intellectual property is the
one who's gonna make a pile of money
from this he planned ahead in ways that
those other people didn't of course he's
not actually gonna make most money
anybody makes from NPM because the
people who are actually gonna make money
from NPM are the venture capitalists who
invested in it people who truly do well
in this story the people who had money
to begin with people who had nothing to
do with javascript effectively own our
language commons what is our language
commons shall i define that let's do it
commons in english means the resources
available to everybody it's like natural
resources like the air we breathe or a
field that we all share to graze our
sheep shared
for us in the JavaScript community the
language spec is our Commons that's
owned by an organization that's set up
to allow JavaScript's users to all
co-operators and design and build it
tc39 is done pretty well by javascript
all of our shared code is part of our
JavaScript Commons the registry that lit
lists all this shared code is part of
our Commons our conventions we use to
share code in it part of our Commons but
all of that is owned by a VC funded
private company this is the thing we as
a group have given away mr. Ryan Dahl
was here last year right remember that
who's here you know it's do you know and
he had something interesting to say it's
unfortunate that it air is a centralized
privately controlled even repository for
modules and I saw that I wanted to argue
with him about centralization but I had
to agree with his comment about private
control what are the consequences of
private control why is why do I think
that's a problem
well none of us have any input into
registry policies
what gets a package removed for the
registry what's acceptable to be on the
registry how are disputes among people
about package names resolved what
happens when two people fight about a
package name and they can't make up
their minds about it you remember left
pad I bet you remember left pad the UM
publication policy didn't exist before
left pad happened because it didn't
occur to npm the private institution to
think about the use case they've don't
act proactively to solve problems until
they exist until they are like right in
their faces this is like normal you know
you don't have to want to deal with
something until you have to you have no
employment or registry features you
might have a wish list but you don't get
it there's no way for you to contribute
it's no way for you to say you demand
something you want package signing good
luck you're not likely to see it maybe
if a major security incident happens or
a major public outcry happens you'll get
it but it would have to be an
existential threat and don't they hear
that I'm talking about the registry not
the clients the registry is closed
source and the policies that regulate it
are not open to our influence the NPM
CLI is open source but it's unimportant
the API is open for now and the key
building blocks you would need to write
open REO and CLI are all open source and
not under NPM is control but a third of
you use another clients interact with
NPM anyway so the management of our
Commons is opaque to us it will affect
be true and opaque to you until the
company that owns it has a financial
incentive to change it you don't know
what's happening with your package data
you have to trust it there's no trust
without accountability and we have no we
as the JavaScript community have no way
to hold NPM Inc accountable now when I
was there I could tell myself that I
trusted myself at my team and I knew our
intentions were good our motivations
were good and I you know you had we have
to have two FA I'm going to make it
happen this is not a good answer
I was wrong to have relied on that
answer because you had no way to hold me
accountable and test that I was
trustworthy oops
so am I saying NPM is evil Moo ask a
different question and PM is a private
entity in control of our Commons it's
not good it's not evil the question of
its benevolence is the wrong question to
ask
NPM is not a benevolent institution it
can't be one the possibility of its
being one ended the day its owner took
VC funding setting and putting it into a
foundation that decision turned it into
a financial instrument I mean something
very specific when I say that financial
instruments are contracts about money
their widgets that can be traded NPM Inc
the company the thing that owns our
language ecosystem is the thing that
might as well be a collection of
porkbelly's as far as its owners are
concerned I make contracts with each
other and trade bits of it around it's a
means for turning money into more money
it's important to keep this in mind as
you evaluate all of your interactions
with it and that your interactions were
the people who represented it this this
means is look at incentives money is the
incentive for a lot of actors in this
story companies do not love you not even
companies that make something you like
that phrase is a marketing message
designed to get you to mistake the
financial interest instrument for
something that might be your friend that
marketing message is pretty powerful all
right you got a cuddly wombat mascot and
some great stickers at a red emoji heart
and you're like you're onboard right and
PM does not love you and PM can't love
you it's a Delaware corporation founded
as a financial instrument intended to
turn money into more money for a headful
of people you don't know and here's the
other thing nobody believes that message
anymore when I first knew I wanted to
talk to you all about this instead of
just whispering in a corner with friends
I thought I had a really
he'll battle to go the VC funded package
management company was beloved and my
work was one of the reasons why I
participated in this I stood in front of
you on stage and I said that marketing
message what I meant by it was that I CJ
Silverio feel affection for you
stranger I kind of do but you know and
it was true I did I still do but I don't
think anyone can stand up in front of
you now after the PR events the last few
months and think that NPM loves you it's
burned a lot of goodwill in the last
couple of months by choice
deliberately they made the choice they
double down on it and here we are you're
willing to listen to this now so how did
we get there it's 2018 packages flow
like water you just you don't care where
they come from you just turn on the
faucet and imp in packages come out they
cost money even if you're not paying for
them NPM has been spending venture
capital money to deliver you all those
packages for free this whole time
venture capitalists eventually want
their money back
they want that 10x return on investment
faeces want you to go big or go home
that means they want you to burn your
cash and succeed or fail VC money is
interested in returning the investment
there's nothing wrong with that in my
view you know some companies are shaped
like VCS want a shape I don't think
that's really the problem the problem is
that our language ecosystem is there
remember that their obligations are the
people who owned NPM not to us make
money or raise money by telling a story
about making money to raise money to
money it's all about the money
so in 2018 to hired a new CEO it's
pretty interesting things got it yeah
the culture the culture that they
exported as their marketing message
started to look a little threadbare
right around them
everyone including me learned that it
was just a marketing message and not
actual deeply held values man p.m.
spirit rebels are known to all of you as
a result we're a community that enjoys
drama have some drama but even if it had
somebody who is a good actor at its head
there'd be that person would have a big
problem to solve and here's the problem
centralized registry is expensive the
part that you care about the place where
all the packages stored is an enormous
strain on Remington's budget and
simultaneously its value to investors it
controls all JavaScript development
because every single view willingly
proxies all of your JavaScript
development through it the data the data
gathered from your usage of it then you
heard a talk about earlier today that's
the value every time you run an audit
npm looks at your package lock
chock-full of interesting data litigants
about what you've been up to
yeah you know what they say about when
you're not paying for the product you
might be the product yeah it's there
thread is dangling over your head right
now I think we're in a situation right
now that is not going to last very long
the PM hasn't fully had its reckoning
with its investors or with us it's had
layoffs but we don't know what's going
on inside but the point is the ground
has shifted under our feet a little bit
anyone who wasn't asking if NPM is
stable is now asking that we now know
that it doesn't love us and it doesn't
love its employees either this was not
our only option
story didn't have to go this way people
chose it and here we are what are we
gonna do about it
you you sitting in this audience right
now what are you gonna do about it you
gonna do nothing that's easy
we made our community decision in 2013
and we're stuck with it we wait for
ampere
to fail and when it does not if when
nasty couple of months replacing
registry I don't like this answer
imagine NPM selling to somebody we don't
like corporate pirate somebody takes
over alien companies ever serial it
shakes them down for pocket change
someone who doesn't have an incentive to
keep the registry up somebody threatens
to take the registry down just to see
what we do about it that's possible
quite frankly because NPM the Board of
Directors hasn't done a very good job
maybe will be saved by Microsoft
microsites in slake 1987 I remember when
Microsoft was actively evil I believe
they might be again certainly Google is
not benevolent purely but I've learned
actor right now even though there you
know got fountain some money I would
like to avoid having to come here tens
from ten years from now and make the
same talk again I think in the end I
agree with Ryan Dahle JavaScript's
packaged registry should not be
privately controlled like centralization
is a burden that will inevitably lead to
a brighter control because the server's
cost money and that's just a fact but I
think if we do out under many people we
can share this burden and who knows
maybe once it's from under the burden of
having to run to the private registry
NPM can like be a normal company and try
to make a profit for itself do you think
that's impossible do you think NPM is
entrenched I'm not a big fan of high end
wave pen rigging and I don't like to do
nothing answer and the other confession
I'll make is that I actually believe in
open-source despite everything I think
it's good for us as human beings to give
things away to each other and I think
I'm at peace with the idea that some
corporation is gonna make money from my
work so Chris Dickinson whose isn't it
vacant on Twitter follow him now Chris
Dickinson and I have an announcement we
would like to give something away to you
all right now like to introduce you to
entropic
federated package manager
[Applause]
yes
yes all right it comes with its own CLI
it offers a new API for publication you
heard Kat talking about tink earlier
this is a dream Christa Kinnison and I
have had for several years now and we
offer that file based API is federated
you depend on packages from other
instances we mirror your dependencies so
you remain self-sufficient quirements
list is short we've daughter eyes dit
you slide in with your github account
don't use it yet the project is only a
month old because Chris only escaped
about a month ago so that's when we
started it it's not ready for anybody to
use but it people developing it but we
do want your help
I hear QR codes are really hip so I got
a QR code for you are so on github it's
open source right now tell me you can
get there you can see it chris flip the
bit i have you got a huge list of choose
for you to contribute to right now
I want to go like I've used up a lot of
your time I'm just gonna run down very
quickly what my goals are why I did this
I want to prove to you all that we all
have power we don't have to sit here and
wait for fate to come to us we can be
optimistic we can be proactive we can do
something you have power second
Chris and I are among a handful of human
beings to actually deeply understand
that the problems the language packets
or history has to solve we've spent
years thinking about this and wondering
what we should do and I think that
expertise is needed by our community
right now and we want to share it we
choose to give it away we'll be working
with the open J's foundation on this
we're giving you the gift of our
expertise in artwork third I think it's
right that this pendulum is swinging
away from Federation I think moving away
from centralized solutions is good last
decoration decade has been about
consolidation my service but I think the
coming decade is gonna be federated it's
gonna be cheaper for us all yes
yes take it back
yours belongs to you
let's make a different decision let's
make a different decision okay we made
this decision in 2013 in a made sense at
the time it's time to make a different
one and traffic is the kickstart Chris
and I are giving to this problem so a
lot more to say there's a lot of work to
do on it I want to get to the point
where I can tell you all to use it maybe
next your at this time it's time to move
with their feet again you are good
amazing people capable of building
amazing things most of you are much
smarter than I am I want to hand this
over to you we shouldn't be owned by a
single company our Commons shouldn't be
owned by a single company and we can do
it this is love from two human beings
who are beings capable of love from us
to you what happens next is up to you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]